c'est l'heure de notre second débat il
nous projette dans un peu plus d'un an
26 juillet 2024 la cérémonie d'ouverture
des Jeux olympiques de Paris l'événement
d'une vie puisque la dernière fois que
les Jeux d'été ont été organisés en
France c'était il y a un siècle sécurité
transport infrastructure ou en sont les
principaux chantiers avant d'en débattre
on fait le point avec Samia le chien
merci dans un an c'est bâtiments
accueilleront plus
de monde entier leurs accompagnants à
cheval sur trois communes de
Seine-Saint-Denis le village des
athlètes est déjà bien avancé jusqu'à
3000 ouvriers se relais chaque jour sur
ce chantier lancé par solideo une
structure publique créée pour gérer la
construction de toutes les
infrastructures durables des Jeux
Olympiques après les Jeux ces bâtiments
seront transformés en logement et en
bureau construit en un temps record le
village des athlètes est un chantier
hors norme il s'étend sur 52 hectares ça
représente à peu près 70 terrains de
foot depuis la naissance du projet
jusqu'à aux Jeux Olympiques qui se sera
à peu près dérouler 6 ans on peut
imaginer il aurait fallu trois fois plus
de temps pour construire l'équivalent
avec des procédures classiques une
course contre la montre qu'il faut mener
sur une soixantaine de chantiers
essentiellement des sites de compétition
et d'entraînement à livrer au printemps
si les violences urbaines de ces
derniers jours ont pu faire craindre des
retards sous l'idéo assure que tous les
chantiers seront livrés à temps pour
l'été prochain à ce jour seul la piscine
du Fort d'Aubervilliers a subi quelques
avaries c'est lié à l'incendie du dépôt
de bus qui a endommagé très légèrement
la façade ça n'a pas touché la structure
ni les espaces intérieurs et donc ça
n'aura pas d'impact en termes de délais
tous les ouvrages seront remis en temps
et en heure à Paris 2024 pour les jeux
la sécurité des jeux en revanche
s'annonce plus compliqué il va falloir
recruter 25 000 agents de sécurité
privée dans un secteur en tension où il
manque déjà 20 000 agents en rythme de
croisière nous sommes à -20 000 et
pendant la période des jeux il faudra
passer à plus 25000 donc il y a une
équation qui est extrêmement compliquée
c'est une montée en puissance
extrêmement forte le tout en un an le
challenge est vraiment à relever pour
attirer de nouvelles recrues le secteur
a créé en accord avec le gouvernement
une formation accélérée au métier de
sécurité privée au lieu de 5 semaines de
formation pour un agent de sécurité
classique qui pourrait effectuer toutes
les prestations n'est que de trois
semaines au lieu de 5 semaines mais qui
permet de faire que de la sécurité
événementielle mais néanmoins qui est
largement suffisant pour la sécurité des
Jeux Olympiques prévus sur les bords de
Seine la cérémonie d'ouverture des jeux
sur à l'événement le plus difficile à
sécuriser la jauge actuellement fixée à
600 000 personnes pourrait être revu à
la baisse et on va en parler tout de
suite avec mes invités je vous présente
Kevin Vaissier bonsoir bien sûr vous
êtes Anaïs en géopolitique du sport
fondateur du site Football Club
géopolitique c'est auteur de ce livre
mondial 22 histoires insolites de la
coupe du monde de foot c'était publié
aux éditions max Milot Florence berthoul
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes mère horizon du cinquième
arrondissement de Paris Mathieu
zagroseki bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
aussi chercheurs associés au centre de
recherche sociologiques sur le droit et
les institutions pénales et spécialistes
des questions de sécurité Mathieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés on a terminé le sujet de Samuel
déchire par des images de la scène
effectivement cette cérémonie
d'ouverture quelques chiffres 116
bateaux 10000 sportifs 600 000
spectateurs on y reviendra sur ce
chiffre sur 6 km de de fleuves et pour
le président du comité d'organisation
des Jeux Olympiques Tony estanguay il
faudra marquer les esprits dès le
premier jour il nous le dit en anglais
la cérémonie d'ouverture est en quelque
sorte la signature de l'édition des jeux
et nous voulions vraiment que les jeux
de paris 2024 montre ce qu'ils ont à
offrir
en trois heures le monde entier doit
comprendre ce que sera Paris 2024 Big
Bang wave Paris
nous permet d'avoir tous les éléments
présents ce sera très spectaculaire
ça promet effectivement Kevin WC on va
déjà rappeler une évidence une cérémonie
d'ouverture de jeux olympiques sur un
fleuve ce n'est ça n'est jamais arrivé
oui c'est sûr c'est inédit d'habitude
c'est effectivement plus dans des stades
qui illustrent effectivement des
cérémonies d'ouverture qui sont à chaque
fois très iconiques qui mettent en avant
un petit peu le tempo de l'événement et
qui ont à cœur en tout cas de montrer
que le pays en tout cas il est à la
hauteur de cet événement mondial qui va
être vu par des milliards de
téléspectateurs et donc tout l'enjeu
effectivement c'est de savoir comment
est-ce que cette cérémonie va pouvoir
s'organiser effectivement dans un lieu
qui n'est pas un stade un comment dire
une instance
non dans les rues de la ville il y a eu
effectivement d'autres qui étaient
présentes voilà d'autres nouveautés
présentes dans les stades mais jamais
sinon ça n'a été sorti du cadre du Stade
olympique on va dire Florence Bertou
quand vous avez entendu cette idée vous
êtes quoi c'est de la folie mais ou
alors génial la l'audace française
on a envie d'y croire mais enfin je veux
dire quand on est un élu responsable oui
on se pose des questions tout tendance
politique confondues d'ailleurs parce
que la scène est c'est magique mais
enfin c'est objectivement extrêmement
compliqué
à sécuriser donc le risque c'est que
pour accueillir peut-être vous avez dit
un spectateurs je pense honnêtement il
va falloir revoir un petit peu la
voilure quand on échange avec des
représentants de la préfecture de police
notamment on voit bien qu'il y a une
forme quand même un peu de de d'anxiété
voilà donc
il faudrait pas que le prix à payer ça
soit que les riverains vous voyez
soit un peu
mis de côté parce que déjà on a fait
savoir par exemple aux habitants des
péniches qui n'auraient pas le droit
d'avoir des invités sur leur péniche
donc on voit bien que la sécurité est la
carte postale parce que ça sera et on le
souhaite tous que ce soit une carte
postale et bien génère évidemment des
contraintes qui sont absolument
pharaoniques c'est effectivement
gigantesque Mathieu zadroski sur le le
nombre de personnes effectivement quand
on dit 600 000 c'est 100 000 dans la
partie basse avec des places payantes
j'ai bien compris et 500 000 dans la
partie haute avec des places gratuites
est-ce que vous vous êtes d'accord avec
lanceur pour dire c'est pas tenable il
faudra moins de monde
déjà qui est 600 ou 300000 personnes je
pense que pour les riverains ce sera
l'Enfer quoi qu'il en soit ça va générer
des contraintes en termes de circulation
de liberté de circulation absolument
gigantesque c'est beaucoup oui c'est
beaucoup de monde 600000 c'est vraiment
énorme ça suicide des inquiétudes à la
préfecture de police je confirme ce que
dit ce que dit Madame Bertou parce que
il y a un enjeu déjà de gestion des flux
mais il y a aussi un enjeu
d'acheminement des secours en cas
d'incident si vous avez autant de monde
sur les quais pour faire venir une
ambulance pour faire venir un équipage
de police pour intervenir parce que
quelqu'un fait un malaise parce qu'il y
a une échou fourrée c'est très compliqué
donc il faut renforcer les moyens
fluviaux notamment la brigade fluelle de
la préfecture de police qui a ma
connaissance aujourd'hui et pas outillée
pour pour gérer quelque chose de cette
ampleur alors ça vous parlez de vous
parler de d'un point crucial qui est la
question de des effectifs c'est-à-dire
que on voyait dans le sujet d'ouverture
que on est face à un défi quasiment
impossible à tenir alors là ça concerne
ça concerne aussi la sécurité privée
c'est-à-dire que il faut recruter 25000
personnes et il en manque 20 000 c'est
vous nous confirmez ces chiffres oui je
vous confirme ce sont les chiffres les
chiffres qui circulent et en fait cette
problématique de recrutement en vue des
JO est en réalité une problématique qui
existe depuis 2 ans depuis le covid en
fait dans le sport professionnel en
général et notamment dans les
compétitions de football qui sont celles
qui attirent le plus de monde c'est avec
les clubs de Ligue 1 et Ligue 2 ont
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à recruter des
stadiers parce qu'une pénurie dans le
métier c'est très simple quand il y a eu
le covid la fermeture des stades faut
pas oublier que saison 2020 2021 elle
s'est joué intégralement soit huis clos
soit je jauge très limité à 5000
personnes donc il y a beaucoup de gens
dans la profession qui se sont
reconvertis qui ont quitté la profession
de la sécurité privée qui sont allés
faire autre chose ou font toujours la
sécurité privée mais dans d'autres
domaines que le sport et jusqu'ici on
n'est pas parvenu à rattraper ce retard
à rattraper en fait ce trou qui s'est
créé donc en une année ça va être
compliqué je le disais en lancement
c'est l'événement d'une vie les Jeux
Olympiques pour la première fois en
France depuis un siècle mais Kevin
est-ce que c'est aussi on va élargir un
petit peu on viendra la sécurité un peu
plus tard est-ce que c'est aussi de plus
en plus difficile pour le Comité
international olympique de trouver des
villes candidates en tout cas comme on a
pu être éloigner pour 2024 et pour 208
c'est de plus en plus compliqué puisque
Paris 2024 avait obtenu cette
candidature finalement puisqu'il y avait
deux candidatures pour 2024 Los Angeles
et Paris et le CIO avait fait le choix
que ce soit Paris pour 2024 et
2028 en 2028 et le CEO avait mis en
avant la qualité des candidatures pour
le fait qu'il n'est pas pu mettre
finalement faire un choix mais c'est
surtout que les autres candidatures qui
étaient en bourre Rome notamment c'est
des retiré puisque il y avait un coup
trois important pour finalement le
contribuable derrière donc il y a de
moins en moins de villes qui sont en
tout cas quand il y a pour les Jeux
Olympiques et encore plus si pour des
Jeux olympiques d'hiver où il y a des
infrastructures importantes mais aussi
pour les Jeux Olympiques effectivement
où on voit qu'effectivement c'est c'est
Paris effectivement qui a eu cette
obtention pour 2024 on est à quel budget
là parce qu'on était parti à 6 milliards
six
tu es à huit fin 2022 le Cours des
comptes nous a dit 8 milliards et on
voit bien que on est gentiment en train
d'aller vers les 10 milliards et encore
et encore en intégrant pas par exemple
et ça peut se comprendre mais la
prolongation de la ligne 14 qui coûte 3
milliards d'euros qui aurait été prévu
mais dont on considérer que c'est
l'héritage du jeu
bien sûr sur les 10 milliards il y a
3000 il y a 3 milliards de fonds publics
vous avez bon la dépollution de la scène
qui est quelque chose de formidable 35
ans après l'avoir annoncé on le fait moi
je peux que dire bravo
88 mais c'est un milliard quatre donc ce
que je veux dire c'est que il y a des
investissements vous l'avez évoqué au
début de votre reportage qui vont être
pérenne il y a d'autres choses qui
seront évidemment moins pérennes et ceci
explique cela c'est vrai que les Jeux
Olympiques d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'il y avait eu de beaucoup de débats
au Conseil de Paris au moment de prendre
la décision même de se porter candidate
qui avait fait l'objet de vote une
partie de la gauche d'ailleurs y était
opposé les écologiques pour des
écologistes pour des raisons d'ailleurs
de de coûts écologique parce que ça
forcément un coût écologique même si les
efforts sont considérons aussi mais
voilà mais ça veut dire quoi ça coûte
aussi de l'argent au budget de la vie de
Paris
budget de la Ville de Paris ça coûte
indirectement sur les médias je ne sais
pas on verra la Cour des comptes nous
fera nous fera les comptes c'est le cas
de le dire à la fin mais ça coûte
directement et indirectement et puis
évidemment à chaque fois on regarde la
nôtre regardez les JO de Londres
regardez les JO de Rio la note a été
multipliée par trois pas par deux par
trois on attend des recettes aussi avec
ces jeux est-ce qu'il y a dans
l'histoire des jeux des jeux qu'on a
déjà été rentable
Atlanta plus compliqué parce que c'était
des jeux qui étaient financé par
Coca-Cola finalement là c'est vrai que
le discours pour ces JO là c'était de
dire que les jeux qui finance les jeux
mais c'est vrai que dans l'histoire des
jeux il y a toujours eu des jeux qui
étaient finalement déficitaires et où
l'enveloppe était finalement plus
globale l'exemple que lequel on peut
comparer ceux de Paris c'est
effectivement les Jeux de 2012 de
Londres puisque ils avaient déjà des
infrastructures présentes et pour Paris
effectivement on voit que là on est à
8,8 milliards on va très certainement
être autour de 10 milliards et encore
dans le budget de 8 milliards je crois
que le les coûts par rapport au niveau
de la sécurité ne sont pas pris en
compte donc effectivement on va avoir
forcément un budget qui va dépasser à
l'autre mais voilà pour organiser des
jeux olympiques qui sont bien plus que
du sport aujourd'hui des Jeux Olympiques
modernes c'est bien plus que 10
milliards d'euros en tout cas pour les
organiser la partie sécurité dans un
budget comme celui-là c'est il y a eu
beaucoup d'argent investi depuis
quelques années pour pour on va dire
j'ai employé un anglicisme
upgradé pour améliorer notre niveau de
sécurité oui alors il y a deux choses il
y a deux choses différentes à prendre à
prendre en compte c'est
la dépense pour la sécurité en tant que
telle par exemple justement le
recrutement d'agents de sécurité privée
et puis il y a les recrutements pour de
policiers ou gendarmes ou là aussi on
peut estimer c'est comme la ligne 14
c'est quelque chose qui va perdurer on a
recruté des fonctionnaires de police et
des militaires de gendarmerie donc ce
sont des gens qui vont qui vont rester
en poste sur ce dernier volet on est sur
une augmentation sur les 10 dernières
années en terme d'effectif de policier
de gendarme de l'ordre de 10-12000
policiers et le budget de la sécurité
intérieure sur les cinq dernières années
et passer de 17 à 21 milliards d'euros
donc alors après c'est tout ça c'est pas
spécifiquement pour les JO le risque
toujours pour une compétition comme
celle-ci c'est le dérapage c'est le fait
que au dernier moment on s'aperçoit que
telle chose n'a pas été prévue que on
manque d'effectifs et qu'il faut en fait
remettre de l'argent au panier mais
quand on parle alors là on parle
effectivement de ce que vont nous coûter
à la France et ces Jeux olympiques mais
en termes de rayonnement international
est-ce que le jeu en vaut la chandelle
d'après vous alors juste un petit
complément sur la sécurité on dit
aujourd'hui que il y aurait 500 millions
d'euros enfin ça c'est ce que un peu les
experts 500 millions d'euros qu'on n'a
pas intégré dans le budget prévisionnel
bon 500 millions d'euros pour ces
fameuses agents de sécurité dont je vois
d'ailleurs le mot le chiffre qui grimpe
parce que vous avez annoncé 25000 mais
souvenez-vous il y a quelques mois
encore on disait 22000 et puis on disait
les gendarmes et les policiers bon bah
mais évidemment le rayonnement
international est-ce que Paris on a
vraiment besoin le rayonnement ça le
rayonnement est considère mais c'est pas
Paris c'est pas que Paris là c'est c'est
la France moi donc
c'est en fait après les jeux les JO
qu'on verra si si le jeu on va aller en
valait la chandelle alors justement si
on compare par exemple reprenons le
comparatif avec Londres est-ce que la
ville de Londres a bénéficié d'une sorte
de de d'effet JO dans les dans les
années qui ont suivi 2012 en termes de
de notoriété de création d'emplois de
notre activité touristique etc etc oui
il y a eu des retombées économiques
importante pour la ville de Londres
n'est pas seulement pour finalement tout
le territoire du Royaume-Uni et à chaque
fois effectivement là aussi pour les JO
il y avait différents qui étaient mis en
place avec des scénarios avec une vision
on va dire très optimiste et puis
d'autres avec des retombées moindres
mais en tout cas oui ce qui est sûr
c'est que la France la ville de Paris et
la France seront mises en lumière durant
cet événement là ce sera vu par plus de
3 milliards de téléspectateurs donc non
cet événement là on pourra voir
effectivement ce qui va donnera après la
compétition mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que ce sera une chance pour la France de
pouvoir se montrer sous son meilleur
visage lors de cet événement 3 milliards
de téléspectateurs ça donne
l'ampleur du défi collectif des filtres
rappelés Emmanuel Macron c'était à 500
jours de la cérémonie d'ouverture devant
quelques 500 fonctionnaires impliqués
dans l'organisation on écoute
au fond quelles sont nos défis être à
l'heure et dans l'excellence en termes
de réalisation
organisation sécurité
billetterie logistique transport
déroulées artistiques et sportifs etc
etc
ensuite être au rendez-vous
de la durabilité
faire des jeux exemplaires et donc c'est
en effet là aussi tout le sujet de la
logistique des transports des mobilités
comme on dit aujourd'hui et de la
réduction des émissions partout où on
peut le faire
Mathieu est-ce que le chef de l'État
joue gros avec ses Jeux Olympiques oui
parce que la date de Paris 2024 a été
coché de longues dates si j'ose dire
dans l'agenda présidentielle pour tous
les enjeux qu'elle représente évidemment
mais aussi parce qu'à l'intervient d'une
certaine façon un mi-mandat et qu'un
incarnera d'un point de vue politique
une forme de bascule du quinquennat en
tout cas de nouvelle étape les enjeux on
les connaît on vient d'en parler ils
sont majeurs pour Emmanuel Macron dont
on connaît l'ambition de laisser une
trace dans l'histoire le chef de l'État
s'est fixé comme mission de recevoir la
planète c'était surexpression dans les
meilleures conditions possibles il en va
de l'image du pays sur la scène
internationale c'est pour le côté
vitrine et depuis quelques mois il faut
bien l'admettre ce rayonnement de la
France a pris un coup avec le long
conflit sur les retraites ou encore les
récentes émeutes dans les banlieues dans
les images on tournait sur les chaînes
étrangères c'est des événements qui ont
conduit quand même à annuler je parle de
rayonnement international la visite de
Rochard vous en souvenez pendant le
conflit des retraites ou à reporter la
visite d'État d'Emmanuel Macron en
Allemagne cette fois-ci à cause des
émeutes en banlieue et pire parce que
au-delà de notre traditionnel réputation
de manifestants révolutionnaires le
béret et la baguette ce sont les
symboles de la République qui ont été
écornés avec la mise en avant de
problématiques sur des violences
policières voire d'un problème de
racisme systémique qui régnerait au sein
des forces de l'ordre de sujets qui ont
été épinglés au début du mois par le
Comité pour l'élimination de la
discrimination raciale de l'ONU par
exemple Emmanuel Macron qui peut qui
veut profiter de ces Jeux Olympiques
pour redorer son blason en quelque sorte
oui mais alors certains opposants l'ont
bien compris comme cela et fin avril le
journal Libération par exemple révélé
que plusieurs jeunes opposés à la
réforme des retraites jeunes moins
jeunes d'ailleurs comptez bien se faire
recruter parmi les 45 000 bénévoles avec
un objectif de ces faux volontaires en
fait pourrir les jeux soit on annulant
leurs revenus au dernier moment donc en
faisant faut bon alors qu'on compte sur
eux soit en perturbant carrément
l'événement c'est dire quand même si ce
problème d'image est quand même
important alors il y a les transports
l'envergement la sécurité on en a parlé
on a entendu le président de la
République le dire le prix de la
République vous le disiez que c'est
permis de mettre un coup de pression
à 500 jours du début des Jeux la seule
chose qu'il a reconnu d'ailleurs dans
son discours que j'ai écouté on ne
serait pas parfait sur tout sur les jeux
il a notamment pointé le problème de
l'inclusion avec notamment les mobilités
de personnes qui souffrent d'un handicap
scène politique nationale Emmanuel
Macron joue finalement assez gros aussi
oui dans un autre registre là c'est
plutôt le côté estime de soi fierté
nationale et puis je parlais de cette
année 2024 qui sera marqué par deux
choses les élections européennes puis
par les jeux et cette année 2024 elle
devait ouvrir mécaniquement une seconde
partie du quinquennat idéalement c'était
le moment où le président a pu changer
de prémunise par exemple pour préparer
la fin la fin de son mandat et
travailler sa sortie mais aujourd'hui
beaucoup estiment qu'après les jeux
commencera surtout la guerre de
succession et qu'on aura un président en
fin de mandat dans l'incapacité de se
représenter qui aura moins de poids pour
imposer ses vues ou ses réformes
force de constater qu'on en est pas
encore tout à fait là encore tout à fait
là effectivement je retiens ce
cette référence que vous faisiez à au
journal Libération plusieurs jeunes
opposés à la réforme des retraites qui
se comptent se faire recruter parmi les
45000 bénévoles votre avis là-dessus
Mathieu zagrodski des taupes en tiges
j'imagine que les organisateurs doivent
avoir ça en tête pas seulement pour
on va dire un climat un peu politique
anti-gouvernement comment c'est comment
c'est vérifié ça comment l'identité des
bénévoles comment tout ça est contrôler
vérifier alors sur le process de
recrutement des bénévoles je j'avoue que
je connais pas les les détails mais sur
ce type d'affaires enfin sur ce type de
de phénomène on peut imaginer que les
services de renseignement et quelques
capteurs et quelques informations pour
éventuellement anticiper ce type de
problème mais après c'est sûr que c'est
difficile de voilà sur des volontaires
qui ont des missions qui sont absolument
fondamentales mais relativement discrète
parfois d'identifier tel ou telle
personne qui aurait l'intention dormir
au jeu
individualisé enfin je veux dire c'est
pas un groupe de surface que vous ayez
une organisation qui va être un endroit
précis et volontaire pour Libération
c'est qu'il y avait plusieurs
motivations il y avait des écolos qui se
veulent protester contre ce qui
considère comme un désastre écologique
qui donc qui était quand même plus
organisé pendant la forme des retraites
il y avait quand même c'était pas une
structure c'est sûr que sinon on serait
au courant mais soulèvement de la terre
ou peut-être pas devenir
bénévole
qui est un peu parallèle c'est celui
aussi de la cyber sécurité dont on parle
pas beaucoup mais qui est un sujet
énorme
mais je pense qu'il va falloir dépenser
plus de moyens sans doute sur ces
questions de cybersécurité qui est aussi
à des risques potentiels que ce soit sur
les achats de billets sur les entrées
etc donc c'est après on a parlé d'une
conférence de presse
voilà que le risque de leur attaque sur
des infrastructures des JO étaient bien
réels et constitué en fait un danger
majeur alors ces questions de sécurité
elles sont aussi au cœur d'un texte qui
a été voté au printemps Jonathan du
priyaze vous pouvez nous rejoindre sur
ce plateau pour nous détailler ce qu'on
trouve dans cette dans cette loi voté
pour encadrer finalement l'organisation
de ces Jeux Olympiques alors c'était un
texte un petit peu fourre-tout mais dans
les dispositions phares de ce projet de
olympique et il y avait notamment
l'instauration de scanner corporel à
l'entrée des stades des mesures pour
renforcer la lutte contre le dopage il y
avait aussi la création d'un délit pour
les intrusions dans les enceintes
sportives mais aussi sur les terrains
sportifs eux-mêmes et ce qu'on avait
surtout retenu ce dont on avait beaucoup
parlé c'était l'article 7 de ce projet
de loi qui a ouvert la voie à la vidéo
surveillance algorithmique à titre
expérimental alors qu'est-ce que c'est
bien c'est simplement des algorithmes
Thomas qui vous pourront se nourrir des
images de caméra ou pourquoi pas de
drone pour repérer plus rapidement ce
que la Place Beauvau nomme pudiquement
des événements potentiellement dangereux
alors ça pourrait être un mouvement de
foule ou pourquoi pas l'abandon d'un
bagage une fois repéré l'idée c'est de
pouvoir le signaler très vite aux
équipes de sécurité qui scrutent ces
rassemblements derrière leurs écrans
mais en aucun cas il ne s'agit de
rechercher des personnes ciblées comme
le rappelait Gérald Darmanin au Sénat
écouter
pouvoir voir raciste alors Gérald
Darmanin et cet employé à rassuré tant
que possible on présentant cette vidéo
surveillance algorithmique comme un
simple outil d'aide à la décision là je
le cite qui serait encadré qui sera
encadré par la CNIL mais beaucoup en
doute ici au palais du luxe en bourg a
commencé par l'écologie c'est Thomas do
su lui il parle carrément d'un
basculement vers une société de
surveillance on l'écoute avec la vidéo
soyons augmenter on passe dans un autre
monde on passe dans un monde où les
algorithmes sociétés privées vont
codifier notre espace public recevons
aussi déterminés par des algorithmes ce
qui est un comportement normal ou
anormal etc et sur lequel on a beaucoup
moins de contrôle beaucoup moins de
liberté c'est ce qui en découle
forcément de ce texte donc nous ce qu'on
reproche à ce à ce ce cet article sur la
vidéo surveillance augmenter dans le
texte sur les JO c'est déjà il n'avait
rien à voir avec les JO qu'il avait tout
avoir avec un basculement dans une
société de surveillance et c'est ça que
nous on regrette
voilà Thomas et ses inquiétudes elles
ont poussé des députés LFI et
écologistes à déposer un recours auprès
du Conseil constitutionnel qui a été
rejeté à la mi-mêle et sage on validait
l'ensemble des dispositions les plus
polémiques de ce projet de loi olympique
que le gouvernement juge essentiel à la
bonne tenue des Jeux et depuis le texte
a été promulgué c'était le 19 mai
dernier merci beaucoup Jonathan Dupriez
Mathieu zagrose qui est-ce qu'on en a
besoin de ces algorithmes pourquoi il
faut pourquoi pourquoi il faut mettre en
place ces systèmes on va dire dérivés de
la vidéo surveillance l'argument est de
dire que
il y a une telle masse de gens qui va
circuler sur la voie publique autour des
infrastructures dans les stades que un
agent des agents de vidéoprotection
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre comment
ça fonctionne c'est quand vous avez des
caméras vous avez un opérateur qui est
dans un local il y a un mur de caméra il
y a différents angles son attention ne
lui permet pas il peut pas être sur tous
les écrans tous les écrans et que donc
il faut mettre en place des dispositifs
d'alerte
attirer son attention sur un fait ou
d'effet qui peuvent nécessiter
l'intervention de service de sécurité
sur le terrain bon il y a l'argument
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit dans la
voilà dans la chronique par rapport à
l'argument sur la société de
surveillance en fait les études un peu
concrètes qui ont été menées sur la
vidéoprotection c'est plutôt l'inverse
c'est qu'en fait il y a beaucoup de
trous dans la raquette alors ce qui est
juste ce qui ne justifie pas forcément
le fait de mettre en place cette société
de surveillance simplement on en est
encore assez loin et pour moi la
véritable question et je plusieurs fois
l'occasion de le dire y compris sur ce
plateau me semble-t-il donc désolé si je
me répète c'est aussi la question de
l'évaluation et du coup c'est que c'est
quelque chose qui va coûter beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent sans qu'on connaisse
véritablement l'efficacité voire
voir en ayant des doutes sur
l'efficacité parce qu'il y a eu des
expérimentations par exemple lors d'une
finale de Ligue des Champions je crois
que ça Cardiff en 2018 je dis pas de
bêtises avec un taux de faux positif en
gros déclenchement d'alerte
en déclenchement de fausse alertes
au bout d'un moment donc les faits et
pire mais alors
parce que quand une alarme se déclenche
de façon intempestive répétitive
alors ça fait un double question d'abord
ce que vous nous décrivez ces 2018
peut-être progresser depuis bien sûr
voilà ça c'est le premier élément et
deuxièmement vous dites ça coûte cher
est-ce que c'est de l'argent qu'on
aurait mieux fait de mettre ailleurs et
si oui ou alors c'est toujours la
question c'est est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
pas investir plus justement dans les
moyens humains sur des gens qui sont sur
le terrain parce que encore une fois
analyse qu'on a du mal à accepter
analysons le processus analysons le
processus vous avez un déclenchement
d'alerte voilà l'attention de l'agent de
vidéoprotection est attiré sur un bagage
abandonné bah il faut envoyer des gens
sur le terrain pour pour intervenir
est-ce que on en aura assez il y a 45000
personnes qui sont prévues je parle des
services de sécurité intérieure je mets
de côté qui ont été privé policier
gendarmes donc c'est à peu près un quart
des effectifs complets de police et de
gendarmerie en France c'est absolument
gigantesque on va aller en chercher dans
des brigades ou des commissariats à
travers le pays qu'on va un petit peu
déshabiller est-ce qu'il aura pas mieux
fallu recruter plus massivement et en
terme de gestion de fou les deux de
maintien de l'ordre est-ce qu'on a tiré
toutes les leçons du fiasco de la finale
de la Ligue des Champions vous pouvez
commencer ensuite qu'il y a une bière je
crains que pas totalement
malheureusement pour moi l'un des
problèmes l'un des principaux problèmes
de du Stade de France donc final de
Ligue des Champions 2022 c'est la
mauvaise gestion des flux vous l'avez
vous l'avez dit et en fait la mauvaise
orientation du public pour avoir assisté
à la finale de la Coupe de France la
dernière Nantes Toulouse il y a deux
mois j'ai vu exactement le même problème
à la sortie du métro c'est-à-dire des
gens qui s'agglutinent sur un point de
contrôle alors qu'un autre point de
contrôle moi je connais bien les lieux
donc je suis allé sur un autre point de
contrôle qui était 400 mètres plus loin
il y avait rigoureusement personne
et aucun agent en fait sur le terrain
pour dire aux gens bah voilà il faut
contourner vous avez une entrée qui
montre conditionnée de l'autre côté
votre avis là-dessus Kevin vestiaire et
le son dont elle était tirée ou pas
après sur le volet sécuritaire je
pourrais pas m'exprimer dessus mais ce
qui peut être intéressant à noter c'est
que on va avoir un autre grand événement
avant les Jeux Olympiques qui ont de la
Coupe du monde de rugby même si le FM
effectivement c'est le temps en 2023 et
finalement ça va être intéressant de
voir comment est-ce que les flux de
supporters vont aussi être gérés même si
on sera sur des des publics de
supporters différents mais ce sera déjà
une première répétition pour l'événement
qui va être les Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 votre avis sur sur ce effectivement
fiasco il y a pas d'autres mots de la la
finale de la Ligue des Champions donc
c'est Liverpool contre le Real je sais
plus si vous l'avez dit alors il y avait
il y avait une grève ce jour-là donc
est-ce que c'est en partie lié à des
raisons conjoncturelles ou est-ce que
c'est vraiment un FIAS sur toutes les
énormes manifestations on sait que c'est
quelque chose de de tout à fait Ess
[Musique]
des transports je vous propose d'écouter
tout de suite le ministre en charge de
des transports Clément Boon qui l'a
annonce qui annonce jusqu'à au max au
maximum pardon 800 000 personnes par
jour pour donner un ordre de grandeur de
l'enjeu qui est le nôtre on va avoir à
peu près 6 à 800000 personnes par jour
de compétition donc c'est comme si on
était en permanence en période de
pointes alors que d'habitude on est en
période creuse c'est à ça qu'il faut
préparer notre réseau de transport
public donc c'est un enjeu majeur on n'a
jamais fait une opération de cette
nature à Paris évidemment il y a
l'Île-de-France mais aussi pour des Jeux
Olympiques puisqu'on veut des jeux 100%
transport public et 100% durable
on sort d'un conflit social lourd de six
mois sur la réforme des retraites est-ce
que ce climat social va peser enfin la
perspective des Jeux Olympiques plutôt
va peser sur le climat social français
pendant les 12 mois
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
on se dirait il y a des arguments à
faire
des interrogations et comme chacun sait
il va y avoir la question de la mise en
concurrence n'est ce pas de la RATP et
on sait très bien que les syndicats sont
un peu si je veux dire
en train de de brandir cette menace
parce que évidemment bah le rendez-vous
le rendez-vous est incroyable quoi pour
faire valoir pour faire valoir leur
revendications donc le climat social va
être aussi un élément qui va être qui va
être très très important et 98 avant la
Coupe du monde le secteur aérien avait
fait monter les autres
c'est pas d'ailleurs exclure mais le
gros sujet c'est évidemment celui des
transports des transports publics Kevin
là aussi si on regarde un peu dans le
dans le rétroviseur alors Mathieu disait
on a une tradition de manifestants qui
n'ont pas forcément les autres pays qui
ont organisé de jeux olympiques
récemment ne parlons pas de la Chine
mais même pour parler des de la
Grande-Bretagne est-ce que c'est un
moment de revendications est-ce que
c'est un moment de de d'avancer social
pour employer les termes chers à
l'intersyndicale dans ce social je pense
pas forcément mais effectivement de
revendications sociales puisque c'est
l'événement qui va mettre en lumière
différentes problématiques je pense
qu'effectivement c'est
nous parliez on se rappelle aussi que
pour un autre type d'événement notamment
pour la Coupe du Monde 2018 qui avait eu
lieu en tout cas en Russie il y avait
aussi des manifestations en amont par
rapport à cela pour effectivement mettre
la pression sur pouvoir politique pour
mettre en perspective d'autres droits et
donc là tu feras aussi s'attendre à des
manifestations
à avoir en tout cas les Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 alors qui dit 800 000
personnes par jour dans les dans les
transports en commun francilien Mathieu
zagrodski j'y arrive
petit pickpocket potentiel ou alors des
touristes qui sont des cibles de de
voilà la tire par exemple ça ça fait
partie des enjeux de sécurité majeurs
[Musique]
touristique moi chez moi dans le 5ème
arrondissement on est particulièrement à
vigilant sur les secteurs touristiques
Mouffetard
uchette et donc ça ça se règle aussi par
des mises en garde et par par des
patrouilles de police municipale il va
falloir que la police municipale sur ses
affaires là soit très très gênantes ça
je trouve intéressant parce que
effectivement ça pose la question des
moyens disponibles parce que les alors
là vous nous dites municipales mais les
policiers et gendarmes qui vont être
mobilisés par les Jeux Olympiques est-ce
qu'ils seront moins disponibles je mets
des guillemets pour s'occuper de la
petite délinquance c'est mathématiques
j'ai envie de dire sauf que si vous
mettez 45000 personnes principalement
dans les glaçons parisiennes même s'il y
a d'autres sites sur lesquels il va y
avoir des événements il y aura Marseille
il y aura Nantes il y aura je crois une
épreuve de tir à Châteauroux bon c'est
un petit peu disséminé sur le territoire
même si
voilà donc il y a d'autres sites mais
vous concentrez
le gros des effectifs dans un endroit
forcément les autres les autres enfin
ils sont pas déshabillés mais ils sont
quand même moins on va dire couverts par
les forces de sécurité intérieure en
sachant que ça lui en plein été avec les
départs en vacances la sécurité routière
à gérer avec les maisons qui sont vides
et donc cibles de cambriolage c'est en
ce moment même une préoccupation pour
les policiers légendaires c'est la
surveillance des des maisons vite parce
que les gens commencent à partir tout ça
ça ne va pas disparaître pendant les JO
alors là on est on est en train de
lister tout ce qui peut mal se passer
mais
il faut quand même faut quand même se
souvenir de ce que ça représente les
Jeux Olympiques en termes de de moments
de
collectif de joie collectives de
première médailles françaises on connaît
à peu près le déroulement de d'un
événement comme celui-là est-ce que
toutes les polémiques sont
potentiellement balayées dès le premier
jour lorsqu'on a une cérémonie
d'ouverture qui qui fonctionne bien
c'est ce qui lance en tout cas
l'événement en tant que tel on a pu
aussi notamment par rapport à la Coupe
du Monde 2022 au Qatar il y a aussi pas
mal même si ces deux événements qui sont
différents mais avant en tout cas cette
première cérémonie d'ouverture et que
les premiers matchs se passaient et
qu'après toutes les controverses
finalement étaient balayées par l'enjeu
sportif on a vu qu'effectivement si
cette semaine d'ouverture réussie et si
après effectivement il y a des médailles
derrière ça peut
balayer les différentes polémiques et
puis après effectivement si la gestion
des supporters si au niveau des moyens
de transport tout se passe pour le mieux
ce sera normalement un événement positif
et après ce qu'il faut aussi reconnaître
c'est que sur l'aspect finalement
d'infrastructures on part quand même
avec job beaucoup d'existants en termes
d'infrastructures pour ces Jeux
Olympiques là les chantiers sont sont
plus ou moins à l'heure on va dire
finalement donc en tout cas c'est un
levier
ce retard pour le pour le retard
finalement il y a pu avoir quelques
retards mais là pour l'instant enfin les
les voyants sont plutôt ouverts et
effectivement il y avait que très peu de
sites à mettre en avant si ce n'est
effectivement le village olympique
le centre le centre de nautique
olympique à Saint-Denis et puis aussi
l'Arena l'Arena et la chapelle aussi est
médias Center aussi effectivement il y a
quelques sites qui ont été confrontés à
la pénurie d'acier notamment pour pour
obtenir le rythme des travaux il faut
quand même rappeler que l'essentiel des
équipements sont déjà existants ce qui
est plutôt le la chose très positive
objectivement parce que on a toujours
tendance à voir le verre à moitié vide
mais ça c'est plutôt positif c'est à
dire qu'on est on a misé sur des sites
qui existaient qu'on a réaménagé et puis
les vrais les créations vraiment de
sites strictosensus sont quand même
résiduels par rapport à l'ensemble alors
c'est ce qui permet d'afficher des jeux
plus propres
plus propres et en plus avec des sites
qui sont censés notamment sur le village
olympique où le média center à voir une
deuxième vie ce qui est très très
importante c'est comme ça aussi que vous
limitez l'empreinte carbone de tout un
tas d'aménagements donc il faut aussi
prendre acte de cet aspect qui est
objectivement très positif qui à mon
avis et plus important que sur les Jeux
Olympiques qui ont été organisés
précédemment y compris à Londres ou à
Rio ou dans d'autres ou dans d'autres
villes bon il y a eu aussi des fiasco la
Grèce c'était ami sur la paille le pays
pendant quand même plusieurs quasi
décennies toutes les grandes
infrastructures sportives seront
réutilisées par la suite il y aura pas
de je sais plus si on obsède des
éléphants blancs ou des
éléphants mais il devrait y en avoir
vraiment pas beaucoup parce qu'encore
une fois les les la création avec
quand même assez assez encadré quoi la
majorité des beaucoup beaucoup existent
déjà votre avis là-dessus ce qui est
intéressant à noter c'est que c'est que
ces Jeux olympiques de Paris on a pu
voir effectivement que les derniers
grands événements sportifs
internationaux c'était la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar c'était les Jeux olympiques
d'hiver à Pékin en Chine et donc c'est
vrai que sur le pic de Paris il propose
une autre vision des grands événements
sportifs internationaux qui sont
effectivement d'avoir vision d'héritage
et de réutilisation des sites sportifs à
l'avenir puisqu'on parle de de des
enjeux écologiques autour de ces Jeux
Olympiques je vous propose de terminer
avec un dernier thème celui de la
propreté de la scène vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure hier la ville de Paris a
dévoilé les trois sites où l'on pourra
se baigner après les Jeux Olympiques le
premier adjoint Emmanuel Grégoire
appelait à quel point les jeux ont été
un accélérateur désolé pour la qualité
du son temps de l'oreille
c'est un moment un peu historique
de son ce que
ton produit pendant des dizaines
d'années sans prendre à bras le corps et
ça on le voit beaucoup aux Jeux
Olympiques si on n'avait pas eu cette
accélérateur je veux dire c'était
événement qui crée un alignement de
force sans doute aurait pris 15 ans de
plus ou 20 ans de plus et donc ça fait
partie vraiment des éléments phares de
l'héritage aux JO
alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure ça date
de Jacques Chirac 1988 la promesse de se
baigner dans la Seine donc 35 ans mais
vous dites le coût est
fan mais c'est très cher c'est un
milliard 400 euros
tout à l'heure pourquoi ça coûte aussi
cher de rendre la scène des spécialistes
pour en parler mieux que moi mais c'est
évidemment un sujet extraordinairement
complexe il a fait du bâtir un immense
bassin de rétention du côté d'austerlit
donc ça se fait pas comme ça et puis il
y aura un autre sujet c'est-à-dire que
pour donner envie à tous ceux qui sont
sur le plateau des beignets je pense
qu'il va falloir aussi que
en dehors de ce de ce centre de
rétention ben on voit plus des vélos
dans la Seine donc c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle le préfet des
régions a lancé un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt pour voir quel serait les
entreprises un peu innovantes qui
permettraient en marge de ce travail de
dépollution qui la nécessité des
aménagements extrêmement lourds d'avoir
de pas voir les bouteilles en plastique
qui donnent pas vraiment envie de se
baigner même si d'un autre côté tous les
marqueurs de dépollution sont auto bleu
mais potentiellement c'est un héritage
des Jeux Olympiques et c'est un héritage
des Jeux Olympiques et moi je me
félicite que
on puisse imaginer se baigner dans la
scène c'est plutôt positif ça veut dire
aussi peut-être qu'il y a vous voyez des
poissons qui vont revenir des espèces
qu'on voyait un peu moins qui vont
revenir et c'est plutôt ça c'est plutôt
positif bon on a on a commencé sur la
scène avec la série d'ouverture on y
retourne en boucle ce débat est-ce que
comment ça se passe je reviens à la
sérénité d'ouverture
Mathieu zagrovski parce que il y a pas
de répétition possible comment ça va se
passer ça
alors c'est c'est de l'anticipation on
se base aussi alors sur le sur le vécu
parce que oui c'est sans précédent le
fait que ce soit sur un fleuve après qui
est des événements de voies publiques
des parades de ce genre de choses on a
on a l'habitude et donc bah oui bah on
met en place un dispositif évidemment
hors norme parce que c'est un événement
enorme il y a une question que je vous
ai pas posée mais je voudrais quand même
terminer là-dessus Kevin vaisselle il y
a un ange sportif
la France elle se classe à quel niveau
en général dans
elle est dans le top 10 mon gars on va
dire avec la 30 et 40 médailles après je
crois que Emmanuel Macron avait voulu 80
médailles mais c'est faudra plus
attendre peut-être un effet Jeux
Olympiques avec 60 médailles mais ce
sera compliqué d'attendre les 80 de
médailles parce que bah ça reste du
sportif et c'est pas en claquant des
doigts qu'on va avoir les performances
si derrière il y a pas eu mais en
général il y a un essai pour les pays
organisateurs oui il y a un effet en
tout cas pour notamment pour les JO de
Londres il y a eu un effet avec plus de
60 médailles et la troisième place au
niveau du tableau des médailles donc
c'est de bonne augure après on verra il
y a que le il y a que sur le terrain en
tout cas que les sportifs devant notre
télévision ou dans les stades pour ceux
qui ont réussi à acheter des places qui
étaient pas si simple merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je rappelle
le titre de votre livre qui est une
vestiaire mondiale 22 histoires
insolites sur la Coupe du monde de
football publié chez Max Millau édition
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro de sens
public je vous donne rendez-vous demain
évidemment vous pouvez également nous
retrouver sur la plateforme public
sénat.fr et puis l'invité d'Oriane
mansigny dans la matinale demain vous
voyez son visage s'afficher Sébastien
Chenu le vice-président du rassemblement
national bonne soirée
[Musique]